welcome back to round seven of the dubai
rapid tournament i want to start off
this video by apologizing
in the last one i said that this video
would feature a staffer gambit
i got confused that's going to be
seen in the next video so stay tuned for
that
um but this game will feature another
favorite opening of mine the london
opening
and we're gonna see uh how it goes for
me so to set the stage i am playing the
lowest rated player
with four and a half out of six points
coming into this round i had four other
six points i was the highest rate player
with that score so
the way that swiss pairings work i do
end up playing a player well below my
rating
but as we're going to see in this game
my opponent was definitely underrated
and it was not an easy game
by any means
so i started off with my bread and
butter opening london system
and my opponent just copies me plays
bishop f5
and normally i am happy going into this
line because usually what happens here
is black plays knight f6
i go for c4 and the very quick queen b3
knight c3 target b7
have some nice kind of positional play
on the queen side
however my opponent was able to
essentially stop me from playing this
plan
by including the very early bishop to d6
and i'll admit this is not a move i
encounter so often but it's a move i
should definitely be ready for because
uh
it turns the position into a much more
symmetrical battle and it becomes harder
for white to play for much of an
advantage so of course i have to react
to
bishop attacking my bishop i decide to
move back
and after knife six
uh the plan of c4 it's a little bit slow
here if i do choose to play c4 then
black can
actually very simply castle and if this
there's lines where black doesn't need
to defend for example knight c6 and if i
take pawn there's knight before
black is already winning here
so i didn't want to risk entering those
lines
and i decided to play
a bit more positionally and went for
bishop to d3 just kind of keeping things
very symmetrical
poland castles
i take
takes and here we see the first sort of
imbalance in the position the double
pawns aren't necessarily weak for black
because there is g6 at black's disposal
but i was happy to get a position uh
going into middle game where there would
be some long-term imbalance
and more room to play for a win
so i went ahead i castle on c6
and i play pawn c4
trying to create more imbalances in the
pawn structure
opponent plays 94
i take
fake and queen b3
so i was actually feeling quite good at
this point because black has an isolated
d-pawn
f pawn is undefended d-pawn's undefended
there's a lot of weaknesses in black's
position and
black is still a bit underdeveloped on
the queen side
now my opponent here took on g3
i took back
and then played pawn to b6 defending the
b-pawn
i go ahead played it to c3
and
here comes kind of the first critical
moment of the game
where
after my opponent took back
i ended up playing the wrong recapture
here
i'm pretty sure i played my move
relatively quickly
thinking it was the best move
but i want to pose this moment
to the viewer this is white to move
obviously there's two options
queen takes c3 and pawn takes e3
the question is
which move to play and why and feel free
to pause the video take some time to
think
this is a more kind of positional
intuitive decision
so i will go ahead and say
the correct move is queen take c3
move i played with pawn take c3 we'll
come back to that
the reason why queen takes c3 is much
better
is because it's a bit more prophylactic
in nature i'm preventing the knight from
developing to c6
i'm also controlling the c file very
quickly with the idea of rook c1 next
and if we look at the natural line let's
imagine 97 rook c1
i'm already
in position to play queen c7
and start kind of crashing through on
the queen side
if my opponent tries to neutralize the
file with rook c8
i can very nicely put the queen on a3
target another weakness in the position
this pawn on a7
and uh it's a little bit tricky for
black to play because the queen is a bit
tied down to defending the rook if a
move like
a5 is played
i can move back hitting the pawn it
actually looks like black is losing a
pawn in this position
as there's there's no great way to keep
d5
and b6 well defended for example if
knight to f6 i can take
then win the b6 pawn
and i know that's kind of a long sort of
specific line but the point is to give
kind of a general idea of how white can
capitalize on the weaknesses in black's
position
after playing queen takes c3
now what i did in the game was pawn
takes c3
and the reason why this isn't as good is
because i give up the
the most powerful like potential weapon
in the position the c file even though i
am planning to play c4 and get two
center pawns and zero center pawns i am
giving black a bit easier play and
easier development
here my opponent plays knight c6 which
turns out to be a really nice move
because now knight a5 is a substantial
positional threat
to
start targeting the c4 square
so i go ahead play c4 immediately
and at first i know this looks like it
loses a pawn to knight a5 but my plan
was to play queen c2
and if knight takes c4 i would take back
and still have good chances to play for
an advantage here given that d6 is weak
and uh there's potential on the king's
side to attack
so
my opponent didn't play 95 instead took
on c4
and here the game became just very
positional and it was a matter of both
of us trying to find
the optimal setup for our pieces
opponent plays rook c8 aligning with my
queen
i play queen b5
sneakily hitting the pawn
opponent defends it
i play rook c1
queen d6
rook t1 a lot of these moves very
natural
and now here after knight to b4
a nice move for my opponent
now there's tension between the rooks i
have to be somewhat concerned about a2
falling there's also the idea knight d5
which is just a very nice central square
for the knights
so i go ahead i save my a pawn with pawn
a3
one plays knight to d5
and after queen a6 knight c3
i realize that i'm not really much
better here at all
like even though i have the center pawns
it's a very stable structure
black just also has a really nice setup
and here i have to be a little bit
cognizant of the tactical ideas for
black
if i'm not careful and play a move like
rook d2
then all of a sudden 92 and i would be
losing uh rook for knight after takes
and takes
so
i had to put the rook back on e1
now we should know here that the same
tactic doesn't work
uh because my queen defends e2 if my
queen were for example let's imagine
like here here
if it weren't covering e2 then knight e2
would again win the exchange
but
thankfully my queen was covering the
square and after rookie one my opponent
played rook to c7
defending the pawn also preparing the
double up
and so far like during this game i
realize my opponent
is not actually a 1 500 strength
and if this were something like guess
elo i would guess probably around 2000
now i did look up my opponent after the
game
and he's rated i think around 1900 2000
just classical fide
so um definitely a very capable player
and uh goes to show in chess that you
sometimes you can't just play against
opponents rating you just have to play
the board and make the best moves
possible so here i play 95 centralizing
my knight
opponent doubles up rooks on the c file
and i play king h2
just trying to get out the way of
potential knight checks
if i wasn't careful and play some dumb
move like f3
and 92 would really hurt me because
there's now a battery and i'd be losing
some material
so king h2 i thought was just a safer
place for the king
but here my opponent plays f6
chases away my knight and plays h5
i was starting to feel the pressure
given that the knight is very very
stable on c3
and all of a sudden there's potential
for h4 and rook swinging over
and the queen is also aligned with my
king meanwhile my queen is just kind of
sitting on the sidelines
watching all the action from afar but
not really participating in the game
so here i just tried to make the best of
the situation played knight to f4
regarding the now undefended g6 pawn
my opponent defended
uh which after king g7 it does block
rook h7 but it opens up rook hates so
there's still some concern for me on h
file
i go ahead and play rook c2
and now king h6
so slightly mysterious move but maybe
just getting away of the potential
knight check on e6
i play rook c1
and after g5 knight e2
this is where
most of the pieces start coming off of
the board now i wanted to keep tension
in the position but of course if i'm not
careful and don't go for trades this
move h4 is coming and uh for example if
i play a move like knight d3
h4 and this could be really really scary
with the pawn pinned 94 in the horizon
and i thought 92 it's just a move to try
and survive
and this does lead to the trade of the
knights and also all of the rooks
after it takes takes takes takes takes
takes
we now reach a uh pretty much completely
equal
greenpawn ending
where yeah the structure is still
imbalanced but i thought that
realistically it's going to be really
tough winning this position
i do have one pass pawn on d4
but black has a queen side majority can
very easily create a pass pawn on queen
side
not to mention there's still some
attacking potential with h4 for black
and
there's cases where my king
will have less shelter if we do see the
trailer pawns
so here i just had to keep fighting and
try and keep playing the best moves
as i could
so my opponent went ahead and played h4
uh just going for some more trades
i played queen d3
we traded on g3
and here my opponent played f4 so
clearly going for just total
simplification if all the pawns come off
the board then my chances to win
will be pretty much zero
so um i was looking for ways to keep
some tension in the position
and i decided to take once on f4 and
after it takes back i played e4
now this does give black the opportunity
to discover check
and trade off uh another pawn
i thought if this did happen i would
move back
and if takes i could start harassing the
king
win the pawn with check
but if we enter this line i think it
would be
most likely just a draw
one of us is going to start perpetually
the other
instead my opponent played the move king
to g5
keeping the option open of pawn f3
and if we notice a king is very
difficult to check
from the g5 square
i do have queen b5 check but and black
just moved back and i don't really make
any progress
so here i actually realized i have a
small trick in the position
is to start with the move d5
i'm pushing my only pass pawn
and i'm still inviting the potential
discover check
along the diagonal
but it turns out if black plays f3 my
opponent did playlist in the game
uh this is actually a crucial mistake
because it allows me to block the check
with my d-pawn
and suddenly just seize initiative hit
the queen
this pawn on f3 uh just doesn't scare me
so much
the queen has one check queen h7 this is
what happened in the game
i will mention that if black didn't play
f3 and just simply blockaded the d pawn
it would have been really really hard to
make progress
but
we went for this line f3 d6
queen h7
i moved my king back to g1
and here i was beginning to breathe a
sigh of relief
especially after my opponent's next move
pawn takes g2 now of course my opponent
is threatening a nasty move queen h1 i
don't have time for d7
but i do have time to force a trade of
queens
with the move queen g3
forcing the king to the h-file and this
is what happened king h6 queen h4
and here my opponent resigned
it was a very abrupt turn of events
given the position went from
very likely drawing to just completely
winning for me
in the span of a couple moves
but i was very fortunate to come away
from this game with a win
uh protecting my rating even the draw in
this game would have uh done some damage
to my rating given my opponent was over
800 points
low rated than me
so yeah the crucial moment was this
position
uh queen g6 turns out to be the only
move for black to hold equality because
d6 is a very big threat
and i've noticed this sometimes that
especially amateur level play
when a player delivers discover check
it's sometimes easy to overlook the fact
that
it's not the piece moving that's doing
the checking
it's a piece being unleashed so it's
possible my opponent just missed my
chance to play d6
and i was very fortunate that turned
into a winning position
so just to show here if my opponent
blockaded the pawn
i would happily take go up upon
queen d5 coming and uh it still takes
some work to convert but this would
still be winning for white
um so that's about it for game seven
played the london could have gotten
advantage out of the
kind of mid to late middle game
uh opponent played really really well to
not only neutralize my my play
but outplay me at some point i was
probably worse at some point in this
game
and uh okay i walked away with a win
this put me at five and a half out of
seven in the standings with two more
games to go
so this time i'm not lying
next game will feature a staffer gambit
stay tuned it'll be a fun one
don't forget to like and subscribe
as always if you have questions
leave them in the comments below and
i'll see you in the next video